bien, dans ce village nous préparons 3 caves
afin qu'en cas de bombardement, tous les habitants
villages réunis dans ces caves en quelque sorte
survivre à ce bombardement survivre d'une manière ou d'une autre
[musique]
Eh bien, ce n'est pas loin de ce village.
positions militaires dans lesquelles nos
les militaires et nous, pour ainsi dire, en cas de bombardement
attaques russes contre l'ukraine nous aidons
militaires pour sentir ces flics et tous ne sont pas
positions pour qu'ils puissent défendre leurs occupations
toute l'ukraine
Étais-je en vacances
c'est-à-dire qu'au mieux de leurs capacités, les enfants
essayant de soutenir les défenseurs du pays
car littéralement ils
toute leur enfance passée derrière le dos des soldats
à quelques centaines de mètres de chez nous
8 ans depuis la fenêtre de la chambre des enfants et dans la maison
la ligne de front est visible et alors si nous
afficher les canapés
ou
parce que les démons sont hitlériens
détonation